Oh,
the followings was a military
formation of infantry armor.
The spirits developed by the Greeks and
you use an ancient warfare and comes
from the word for long Joe's
meaning finger, which is
also where we get to work.
Phalanges and English.
Anatomy is the earliest use of
spirit formations like the felons,
but it's not Greek.
However,
there is evidence that the Sumerians
Egyptians and many other civilizations use
spear like formations like the Phalynx.
However,
it was arguably perfected by
the Greeks and Macedonian.
Here's how it works.
Armored soldiers get together and close
file and the front row walks their
shields together,
forming a wall next to first few front
rows would point their spears forward to
creating rows of them. The fellas would
then advance and a strong slow pace.
The Shield wall protected against other
infantry and projectiles while the
spirits protected against cavalry and
infantry Feliks was not invincible.
Though it was most effective in flat
terrain and if broken even for a short
duration,
the formation can be doomed.
The most famous success of the fellas
was that the battle of marathon in 490 BC
here, 11,000 Greeks. If feed
a 26,000 invading Persians,
but this formation there was also the
battle of Thermopylae and 480 BC where the
300 Spartans along with the list famous
700 thespians and 400 Stevens held off
the advancing Persian
force using this formation.
There was also the Macedonian fellings.
He goes by Phillip to second of
Mastodon and his son Alexander the Great
Alexander the great uses felling said,
conquered the Persian empire and created
one of the greatest empires of his day.
Eventually though, by the time
of the Roman invasion of Greece,
the felling have become
less and less effective.
Emperor Caracalla of Rome did actually
try to create a felling snow third
century Aidy by making a regimen
of 10,000 Macedonian men,
but afterwards it had
fallen in the history.
This video is made possible by the
support of Macedonia ball on Facebook for
humorous content relating to this subject.
I would encourage you to like their page
on Facebook and from our videos about
military history, history
in general, and much more.
I would encourage you to subscribe
and check out my channel.
Thank you for watching.